I'm very happy to be joined today by
someone whose work I I've admired very
much. I've interviewed him very many
times and this is the first time that
we're connecting face to face and that
is Raymond Ibrahim, a very serious
scholar about the relationships between
the West and Islam. Raymond, good to
meet you. Thank you for your time today.
>> Hi, Father McTig. Great to be with you
again.
>> Raymond, I want to have a difficult
conversation about the issue of
assimilation into the West. As you know,
in the United States, we've got this
notion that if we just sing rousing
choruses of all our welcome, people will
stream across the border, there'll be
vibrancy, there'll be interesting food
to eat, and we'll all live happily ever
after. I want to par put parenthesis
around the American experience for a
moment and and focus on Europe. Uh
Europe has a u shall we say a rather
contested
uh history with Islam going back to
Charles Mortell the battle of tours the
issue of the reconista in Spain uh
Christians and Muslims haven't always
gotten along but the heirs to the
enlightenment have assured us that we
can get along with everybody if only
we're reasonable and that one of the
best things that Europe can do right now
is to uh welcome unlimited adherence of
Islam. Uh give them all the access to
the welfare state. There'll be vibrancy.
There'll be contribution. Uh the
enlightenment will be vindicated
once again.
I'm a student of history of human
nature. You are as well. What are you
seeing in response to that proposition
that Islam can fit in cozy into a
post-Christian West?
>> Well, the whole concept of assimilation
is uh you know, you mentioned the heirs
of the enlightenment and so forth who
cling to this. I think it's uh
inherently built upon a materialistic
principle or premise. Um sure if every
human being is a materialist that is to
say an atheist to some degree and uh
your entire life is based on the
material comfort food you know shelter
enjoyment pleasure etc the physical then
yeah you know if every human gets to
that point I suppose we could all
assimilate in something like America or
into Europe but that's kind of arrogant
and it's egotistical because it's
self-centered and it's based on the
western current western paradigm other
people specifically ally Muslims have an
entire world view that of course there's
the materialistic side but it's a very
abstract theological worldview and it
just so happens that this world view
completely clashes with so many of what
the west takes for granted as uh you
know human rights freedom of religion
dignity of the human etc. Uh so uh you
mentioned history of course and that
itself is one long um manifestation of
what I'm discussing which trace which
goes back to the Islamic doctrines and
teachings in the Quran in the hadith
etc. We can talk about that at some
point. But yeah, the history and I'll
I'll bring in a recent anecdote I've
been studying that not many people know,
but the EU because you mentioned Europe,
of course, the EU, the European Union is
spending something like over 10 million
um euros on a project that's called the
European Quran. And when you look into
this project, it's all about trying to
convince Europeans that Islam and the
Quran have always belonged on the
continent. Okay. Uh and it's just
amazing uh you know the chicainery they
get they involve in. Go ahead. You want
to say something?
>> Well, I I think back to when they were
forming the uh the European Union and
the preamble to the Constitution and
they were talking about sources of
European identity. there was a
deliberate choice not to mention
Christianity, which is like trying to
talk about the history of China without
mentioning the emperor. So apparently
there's a gag order on the Christian
sources of Europe, but somehow Islam has
always been here. Is is that what is
that what I'm hearing from?
>> Absolutely right. So in as much as you
know the Christian heritage of Europe
and the West in general is constantly
sidelined and uh pushed out of the way
even though it of course fundamentally
belongs there. They're trying to
introduce essentially the historic enemy
number one of Christendom as being one
of the major contributors to the
European identity. And it's just it's
it's mindboggling for those of us who
know a little bit of history of course u
but it's not intended for us. is
intended for the dumbed down, you know,
generations and newer peoples uh to just
buy into it and believe it. And they
even make clear on their website the
European Quran, they even say after
getting into, you know, how they're
they're re they're challenging uh uh you
know, European identity by bringing this
up, they say that this is also being
done for current present reasons. So
basically they want basically in as much
as diversity is creating all the
conflict that we see in Europe on a
daily basis they're trying to say no
it's actually been there from the start
and it's you crazy Europeans who are
just for some reason not appreciating
Islam the way apparently their
predecessors did but their pres
predecessors all they did was they were
crusaders and fought Islam. So
>> let me state something obvious. If the
truth is on your side, then you don't
have to lie. And I know enough about
history to know that whole European
Quran project really, it really is is a
lie. There there there's no question uh
about that. The other lie is that well,
sure, maybe, just maybe, there are some
Muslims who misbehave every now and
again in Europe, but those aren't the
real Muslims. Those are the Muslim
extremists. Those are the Islamists. And
Raymond, you know, you and I have talked
about on there so many times before. The
idea that an orthodox
Quranbelieving
Muslim is moderate, is agreeable, is
peaceful, has nice things to say about
Jesus and the people of the book, and
it's all a just misunderstanding. Can
you give a quick review as to why that's
just a flatout lie?
>> Well, you know, as all good lies are,
they're based on a little truth. And the
truth here is that yes, you do need a
distinction, okay, between you can't
it's even I won't paint all Muslims with
one brush. There are the the problem is
the words we use. The the dichotomy of
moderate versus radical is a false
dichotomy. The correct dichotomy is
observant in place of radical and uh
laxidasical indifferent cultural Muslim.
Okay, that's the moderate. So uh in the
current language, the moderate is
somehow supposed to be the true
representative of Islam and uh he he
tends to be an okay guy, right? And the
radical, that's the that's the
problematic ISIS kind of guy, but he's
the fringe. He's the weirdo. Here's he's
the extremist. No, the radical or or
what we call the radical is the guy
who's literally following his religion
which is radical inherently. The Islam
is it's a radical religion what it
teaches
>> violence and intolerance for the
non-Muslim you know death and slavery
and concubinage etc. Now the moderate or
as we call him the moderate who I call
just the cultural Muslim or the
secularized Muslim. Yeah, he maybe you
can live with him. Maybe he can
assimilate in the west, but in no way,
shape or form is he a representative of
Islam the way the so-called
radical/observant
Muslim is. So,
>> uh you know, the dividing line is
necessary, but it's being uh perverted
in a way that of course makes it look
like the moder the the that the
non-observant Muslim is the real Muslim
when he's not.
I I want to talk a little bit more about
if truth is on your side that you don't
have to lie. Uh I'm sure you may have
seen over the summer, you know, people
are swimming and so on, public pools, uh
you know, all over the northern
hemisphere. And I think it's it's in
Germany where there has been uh let's
just say dramatic misbehavior usually
invol uh involving the violation of of
women and children. They have these
posters about please don't violate women
and children, but it's depicting uh
white Europeans molesting women with
with head covering, which is numerically
speaking the exact opposite of of of
what has happened. What What's going on
here? How do we explain this? And before
I get into that, it's even worse because
I know exactly the pictures you're
talking about, but some of the pictures
have white European women sexually
harassing dark men in the pool. So it's
not just, you know, white man attacking
a dark hijabed woman. It's it's so
completely topy turvy. What's happening
now is I mean it's very obvious to those
who have eyes to see with and ears to
hear with when you hear these reports
and see this sort of thing which is that
the powers that be the European Union or
whoever you want however you want to
characterize them are just doubling down
and they're they it's become now you
know they've been called out they've
been exposed everyone sees the
gaslighting and instead of you know
trying to you know they're not even in
in they're not even in um you know
trying to damage control it they're
actually aggressive aggressively pushing
it um to the and I I suppose they're
ultimately again banking on the fact
that most people have just become
oblivious and desensitized and they can
get away with the propaganda that
they're issuing via these pictures for
example. Um but then there's people like
us who are just kind of seeing more and
more of the same thing and the message
is no longer resonating. uh it's become
you know when you talk about a place
like the UK it's from what I understand
it's just almost surreal where the
people who are being arrested are the
native Brits because they tweeted or or
said something that is mildly offensive
to um a Muslim or migrants whereas the
migrants are raping and killing and
robbing and destroying and burning and
they barely get their hands slapped. So
obviously and this which really brings
up another point which is uh in as much
as people in Europe and in the west in
general their eyes open up to what's
happening I think it becomes very clear
that the issue is becoming less and less
Islam and more and more the powers that
be who govern you who are nominally on
your side who are nominally of your
people and of your heritage okay they're
the ones who are doing this I've often
given the analogy you know if you throw
in if I take a cage of uh full of lions
and put a zebra in there and the lions
maul it. I'm not going to blame the
lions. I'm going to blame the guy who
put them in there. Right? So, when
Muslims behave the way they behave,
well, we know that's how they behave.
It's been documented for over a
millennium. Okay? Uh that's how it is.
But so when you have a but when you have
the force, you know, whether it's the
leaders of this or that country or the
EU going out of their way despite what's
happening all throughout Europe and just
covering for it like what's happening
this uh you know in England with the
so-called grooming gangs and it just
gets worse and worse the more news comes
out of the cover up uh that was by the
authorities themselves and how if you
speak you get in trouble. So, it's
becoming very clear to me, I think, and
it should be to others, that really, if
you want to pinpoint the source. It's
less the Muslim migrants, uh, they just
behave the way they do. I mean, that's
that's the given, but it's the people
who keep bringing them in and covering
for them and sponsoring them and
shutting you down that are really the
issue at hand.
>> I want to offer a point of contrast.
remember several years ago on YouTube,
they did side byside preparations for
Christmas in Germany and in Poland. Uh
my observations regarding Eastern
European countries is uh they have a
more vivid sense of history and a longer
memory. And so I think that's shown in
the migration policies of of uh of
Hungary and Poland for example. So, in
Poland, uh, they were getting ready for
Christmas and they've got children's
parades and Father Christmas and there's
lights and displays and families
wandering in open streets. And in
Germany, they're putting up a Christmas
tree and a hurricane fence around it
with razor wire with heavily armed
guards. And the person putting up the
YouTube video said, "What's the
difference?
Why do we need razor wire and armed
guards for Christmas displays in Germany
but not in Poland? Well, the answer is
is really pretty obvious, but you're not
allowed to say that. Uh in Britain,
you're arrested if even if no one has
denounced you for what you said was
offensive to me. The power is that be
said, we can imagine someone being
offended. So therefore, uh, off you go
in, uh, in handcuffs. So it seems to be
a forbidden topic. I I know you're
mostly a a historian, but for just for a
moment, could we speculate why does the
formerly Christian West seem to have
such a sense of selfloathing
that it is admitting masses of people in
who obviously hate what the Christian
West and the Enlightenment stand for?
Why is that? How do we make sense of
that? You know, you touch on a very
important um question that I've actually
been pondering for a long time and
increasingly as of late. And um I think
the best way to frame it is as follows.
If you look around the world at various
civilizations and cultures, uh all of
them actually, they all engage in what
we can call ancestor worship or
veneration. They respect their ancestors
and it doesn't matter if objectively
they were good or bad or progressive or
backwards. they just, you know, and
they'll even lie. Of course, this is the
case with Islam where they present
their, you know, forebears in the in the
most um uh glorious and glamorous light,
even though they often just acted like
ISIS. Okay? So in Turkey for example
they celebrate all the time the conquest
of uh Constantinople May 29 1453 and
they praise Mahmed or Muhammad II as you
know and but if you look at what
Muhammad did and mean now meanwhile in
America um men enlightened men from you
know the time of Jefferson their statues
are being toppled because they're
monsters right by their descendants
whereas people like uh you know Muhammad
II who engaged in massacres and orgies
and destruction of churches and
beheadings and all sorts of sadistic
stuff. He's being loved by his uh you
know his his his progyny. So what what
led to this? Why do of all people why is
it that western people have so much
disdain for their own heritage and their
own ancestors whereas everyone else
including people whose ancestors leave
much to be desired still prop them up
which I think is a very human natural
thing to do. And um you know I think a
lot of people when they hear this
question they may think uh they may
think it's organic and they may think
that to a large extent well westerners
became so progressive in their mind and
they you know they so they look at their
ancestors as just backwards and stupid
and silly and you know they don't want
anything to do with them. But I actually
think more and more I think on this
question I think it's actually by design
that there has been an int intellectual
push generation after generation going
back possibly centuries to convince
modern western European man and woman to
hate and break away from their past
their ancestors by portraying them as
fools and backwards and savages. And
this is why you get all this fake
history that presents medieval Europe in
the worst possible light possible. Uh I
think um and uh and the more you do that
and you break away from your own
heritage and your own legacy and your
own
>> Christian mores the more you become a
drift you know you don't have an anchor
in anything and um now you don't care
about your own heritage. How many, like
I said, if you look at any culture,
Chinese, hind, Hindus, Muslims, Latin
Americans, they all tenaciously cling
and venerate their past and their
heritage. Europeans who arguably have
the best and and the most glorious are
the only ones who hate it. So, this
cannot be an organic development. Uh,
and I really do think it goes back and
it's an intentional way to demoralize
and strip Western Europeans Christians
from their legacy so they don't think
and act the way their forebears did
because the powers of be don't want that
kind of thinking and that kind of action
even though it led to the greatest
civilization that everyone wants to go
live in.
>> You know, I there there's kind of an
irony taking place. I mean, I I've heard
those arguments, too, that, you know,
uh, Christians in general, Catholics in
particular, you know, we're the bad guys
and then and then they rattle off things
that they don't have any understanding
about. Well, well, what about, you know,
Galileo and Capernicus and flat earth
and the the Inquisition? I mean, all all
those things. and that Christianity in
general, Catholicism in particular, is
is anti-science, anti-rational,
unenlightened, and the enlightenment
rescued the West from the darkness of
Christianity. Even if you take that at
absolute face value without exception,
why would an enlightenment progressive
science is divine kind of person welcome
in
inherence of Islam on moss and not just
you know great scholars like you know
Avisa or Avarerois but lots of people
who are illiterate in their own language
who marry are their first cousins.
Doesn't this seem to be a sign of if
you're really going to be the advocate
of the enlightenment, why would you be
cheerleading Islam as it's lived in
Europe in the 21st century?
>> Because this is no longer about the
enlightenment. This is again an agenda
that is exploiting enlightenment type
thinking. Um
so for example, it's a good question. I
can be an atheist, a secularist. Why am
I taking in people who are openly so
avowedly against what I believe in?
Right. And again, I I I have to go back
to this, you know, the the powers that
be, the the influencers, the the
indoctrinators of people, the same
forces who made Europeans disdain their
heritage have, you know, so stripped
them of cultural civilizational heritage
that anything goes. The idea is simply,
hey, we're all the same and we all want
the same thing. Material, as I as I
mentioned originally, good materialism.
And so, and besides, why don't you want
multiculturalism? are you a racist? And
then, you know, they got people so
scared of words being called a racist.
>> And best of all, with multiculturalism
and diversity, you have, you know, you
have great cuisine. You know, you can
eat Thai and Mexican and Yeah. So, it's
a win-win, right? Uh for in in a very
superficial sense. So, I think again,
it's the same forces that have tried to
strip Christians and Europeans from
their heritage is trying to fill the
void with something else. And no matter
even if that something else goes against
basic decency even uh and this is what
makes this a very nefarious project in
my opinion. It's not just a matter of oh
we've lost our kind of uh moing and
we're just a drift. It's it's always
intentionally going in the absolute
worst direction that you can possibly
imagine. It can't just be organic you
know. And again, when you look at Europe
where it's already suffering from Muslim
migrants and these masses and these
influx of numbers and what are they
doing? Nothing except doubling down,
concealing it, hiding it, changing the
stats. When there's crimes and, you
know, rape and whatever, they put the
face and the name away of the Muslim
migrant, but if it's a white guy, they
put his face up and his name uh to try
to make it make you think that it's all
the same, you know. And one one last
point relevant to what you've been
saying, but the countries that you
mentioned that don't have this problem
um Hungary and Poland and you can say a
lot and you mentioned the a lot of the
eastern nations um and it's of course
one is because they have a longer memory
and a more recent experience with Islam
under the guise of the Ottomans
specifically.
>> Um you know places like Hungary were
under Ottoman occupation for about 150
years until something like 17 or 1800.
So that's not too long ago. they have
good experience. um you know someone uh
the um Orban Victor Orban for example he
said at one point we he said exactly
what I just said which is we have long
experience with Muslims and uh maybe
that's why we don't want them around but
it's also I think and going back to this
breakaway much of this breakaway of
western man you know arguably you can
say it starts with the Protestant re
reformation because you broke away from
the Catholic Church and in that sense
once you've done that you've basically
nullified 15 centuries of Christian
history from Europe. And so to for many
Protestants, they don't have that
continuity that goes back, you know, uh
because that's the Catholic Church and
that's the bad guy. We want nothing to
do with that. So their own history has
become trunk truncated very short and it
doesn't have much problems with Islam,
right? Once uh once Protestantism comes
in, this is now Islam is waning the
Ottomans and it's still mostly in the
east. So, you know, Britain's not
necessarily fighting or Germany fighting
against the Ottomans, certainly not by
1800. So, it really starts kind of
fading away and uh and even right now
when you see what's happening with the
migrant crisis, the people who are
rising up and fighting back, it seems to
be Catholics. So, in Ireland, they're
getting very vocal uh beyond vocal. in
Spain there's all you know it seems like
there's a civil war brewing uh by
Christian nationalists as they call them
because of what Muslims are doing there.
So I think uh there's also a cultural
memory kind of captured within whether
you're Orthodox and Catholic because
you're closer to Islam um and you've
kind of experienced it or whether you're
Protestant and you've sort of been away
um you don't have much dealing
historically uh with Muslims not ne not
in a negative way really um and I think
that too is kind of manifesting itself
today and this is why Germany when they
do Christmas they have to have armed
guards whereas uh Poland and Hungary
Let's shift a little bit from uh
speculation to historical facts. I'm
going to make a bold statement that
would probably get me arrested in the UK
and you're a historian. You correct me.
Islam is whatever its spiritual
religious claims factually, observably,
empirically is an ideology of conquest.
And that Islam doesn't rest wherever it
goes until it is master. That's my bold
statement. You're the historian. Correct
me if I'm wrong, please.
>> No, you're right. This is uh doctrinally
proven. If you look at the core
scriptures of Islam, the Quran
specifically and the Sunnah which is
derived from the hadith, the words and
sayings and deeds of Muhammad. If you
look at the tephacier which is the uh
the exigesis of said scriptures
especially the Quran and if you look at
the long history of Islam visav the
world I uh in my book sword and scimitar
14 centuries of war between Islam and
the west I document Islam's history with
the west which was all Christian
including the middle east um and if you
look at all those three sources that's
Islam that's its doctrine stated
doctrines that's its theology that's the
life of its prophet and that's how it
conducted itself historically and all of
those emphatically agree with what you
say that this is a creed and a doctrine
inherently built on conquest and power
>> and we see that culturally for example
um uh I know there have been towns in UK
where they've been in churches have been
instructed not to ring the bells because
that might offend the adherence of the
religion of peace and but they're also
setting up their towers and their
microphones for their calls to prayer
and so on. Uh I know that there are
Christians in the UK who have been
arrested outside of abortion clinics on
the suspicion of praying interiorly on
the suspicion and yet when it's time for
prayer in certain neighborhoods in in
London traffic is blocked off
and and and that's and that's okay. and
the the the king of of England who's
supposed to be among other things the
head of the church of England seems to
have an enthusiasm for Islam that I
don't quite understand. So ju just to
reiterate,
it seems to me empirical rather than uh
bigoted to say that Islam is oriented
towards a cultural and a physical
conquest of whatever land people happen
to find themselves in in relatively are
large numbers. And I think the the
canary in the coal mine is the UK
because it's smaller.
I think Germany it's happening writ
large and maybe a place like Sweden is
starting to wake up to the threat that
they're under. What what are your
thoughts on this?
>> Yeah, and you know as you were as you
were discussing what you were saying
especially with the king of England
who's supposed to be the head of the
church and so forth. you know, brings to
my mind a very important point, which is
sort of how and and again, this shows
you how diabolical these things are, but
how, you know, the gospel has been
perverted and weaponized to help what
we're discussing, to help the bad side,
to help Islam do what Islam is doing and
to actually suppress Christianity
itself. And what I mean by that is, you
know, they've taken, it seems to me
today, Western Christianity is begins
and ends with concepts of tolerance,
turning the other cheek, and in short,
being a doormat. Those are the most
sponsored and supported uh, you know,
forms of Christianity, I think, today.
And it's very and and it's, you know,
even non-Christians will support and
prop that message up. Okay? And I think
there's a reason for that. Because if
I'm an enemy of Christianity, I would
want nothing more than for Christians to
think that their duty in life is to be
my doormat and to never object to
anything I say or do because they can't
judge, you know, or be confrontational
or any of these sorts of things. So, I
think I don't and I always mention this,
but I saw in a Super Bowl commercial, I
think a couple years ago, it was so
flagrant. It was just a commercial. All
it showed was images of people washing
other people's feet. Okay? And then at
the end it just it just various pictures
and then at the end it just said
something like Jesus didn't preach hate,
he washed feet. And of course there was
such a political message in in the
commercial cuz everyone on their hands
and knees were sort of traditional white
men and women and the people getting
their feet washed were a woman in a
hijab and a Muslim and a you know an
illegal alien who crossed the border and
a homosexual or as they call them you
know drag people. Um they're getting
their feet washed. So the message is
very clear. You if you want to be a good
Christian, you shut up and if anything,
you just kind of help and serve us, make
us feel good about ourselves. And I
think that has gotten so far and has
permeated the minds of so many uh
self-identified Christians in the West
that they don't realize it's intentional
and it's been done intentionally to gear
them to become, if anything, uh servant
subservient to all of the evil that
we're seeing spread. And so the idea,
you know, I write about crusaders and
and men like that. Those guys are anthma
to the current spirit of the age. And
including many Christians, they're
taught to hate that. You don't fight,
you know. Um but then again, we it seems
people forget Jesus engaged in violence.
>> You know, he whipped people. He threw
tables around. The Old Testament is full
of violence. God promotes war. So uh I
think the idea is uh Christians have
been disarmed many ways intentionally by
sort of uh and that's what a heresy is.
Of course, you just take one aspect and
prop it up and forget about the rest.
There's no balance. And they've been
convinced that to be a good Christian is
to just be a doormat. And topping it all
off, I think so many Christians have
become by nature sort of cowardly. And
so it's it's even easier to do this. In
other words, they make a virtue of a
vice and the vice is cowardice. They
don't want to be confrontational. They
don't want to appear judgmental. They
don't want to get in anyone's face and
call out their evil. Um, and then they
pat themselves in the back and say, "I'm
just being a good Christian." Uh, I
don't think that's the case. You know,
they're just, uh, like I said, they're
they're exploiting Christ's words and
all of it is being done to help this
madness spread.
>> I want to add to something you said. I
agree with you. Christians have been
disarmed and Christ has been uncrowned.
And that's not good for anyone because
Christ, the eternal word of the father,
is the savior. He is the the king of the
universe. Uh one one last topic I I
could talk to you all day. Um if
symptoms persist,
if nothing is done, uh you know, there
are, you know, the the flag in
Minnesota, the state flag has been
revised to look like the Somali flag. Uh
and in the UK, the most common name for
boys born in the UK is is Mohamad. Uh
Christians in the west seem to be
determined to abort and con themselves
out of existence as rapidly as their
secularist counterpart.
Not so much for Muslims. What happens
demographically to the west if nothing
changes over the next 5 to 10 years?
Well, it, you know, a lot of people will
talk about this and they'll say, I think
in the back of most Western, especially
white European people, whether they're
in America or Australia or Europe, the
the problem is when they look at their
countries, whether it's in Europe or the
US, they're still the majority, okay?
Including the United States, including
in Europe, even the worst country with
as many Muslims and migrants, whichever
that may be, the UK or Germany or
France, they're, you know, the the
natives are still the minority. So in
their mind I think they think that oh we
have this we still have this under
control but if you step back and look at
the bigger picture the world okay people
seem to forget that Europeans
you're what whatever word you want to
use Caucasian whites but I mean
Europeans specifically are something
like I I mean the numbers are different
but something like six or 7% of the
world and I just find it amazing that
such a tiny tiny uh population is the
one that feels incumbent on suppressing
everything about itself, welcoming in
everyone into its country, suppressing
its cultural and religious identity lest
it offends the masses. And they're the
ones that have to do this, not anybody
else. Again, here, this is the stuff you
can't make up. This is the stuff that
cannot be organic. This is the stuff
that is intentionally being pushed on
probably from top down um on the world.
And people, like I said, they don't get
it because they just look in their
countries or their neighborhoods and
they still they Yeah. Yeah. I see a
problem. There's the demographic shift,
but still we're we're the majority. But
guess what? In the world, you're a tiny
tiny tiny minority and you've dropped
you've left your gates open and they're
just flooding in. And instead of doing
anything, you you're you're the only
one, not the masses, the millions and
millions. You have to be the one to give
your home away and you have to shut up
and you have to suppress your whole
can't say merry Christmas, can't say,
you know, happy whatever the case may
be. Uh I people need to wake up and take
a close look at that because this isn't
right. This isn't normal. This is beyond
suicidal and it's again it's it's by
design and people need to ascertain the
actual source and address it.
>> No, I I agree with you and Raymond I
want to said I could talk to you all day
so I want to I want to wrap up here. I I
think that we can no longer afford to be
naive about the intention of Islam and
its inheritance as they move into the
West, as they move into the north. We
can't afford to be naive about what
Islam says about itself. And we can't
afford to be naive about what it says
about others who are not Muslims. And
that's why I'm so grateful for your work
is because you're calm, you're sober,
you got the receipts, you know the
history, you understand human nature.
So, I'm grateful for your time today and
I do look forward to our next
conversation.
>> Thank you very much, Father McTagga. My
pleasure and I look forward to it.